Optimal at this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
I'm a cybernetic organism living tissue.
Tim Ferriss show is brought to you by on it.
I have used on IT products for years.
If you look in my kitchen in my garage,
you will find Alpha brain chewable Melatonin for resetting my clock when I'm
traveling.
Kettlebells,
battle ropes,
maces steel clubs.
It sounds like a torture chamber and it kind of is.
It's a torture chamber for self improvement and you can see all of my favorite
gear at [inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim.
That's o,
n n I t.com forward slash Tim and you can also get a discount on any
supplements,
food products.
I like hemp force,
I like Alpha brain.
Check it all out on it.com forward slash Tim,
the Tim Ferriss show is also brought to you by 99 designs.
99 designs is your one stop shop for anything.
Graphic design related.
You need a logo,
you need a website,
you need a business card or anything else.
You get an original design from designers around the world who submit drafts for
you to review,
you are happy or you get your money back.
And I have used 99 designs for book cover ideas for the four hour body,
which went to Number One New York Times for banner ads.
And you can check out some of my actual competitions@ninetyninedesigns.com
forward slash Tim,
you can also get a free $99 upgrade if you want to give it a shot.
That's 99 designs.com forward slash Tim.
Hello ladies,
gents.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
I deconstruct world class performers to figure out what makes them tick.
And Moreover,
what are the tools,
tricks,
tactics,
routines,
books,
whatever secret snacks that you can replicate that you can actually use in your
daily life or in your career or in your personal endeavors and your journey into
life itself.
Wow,
that was profound.
Anyway,
my guest for this episode is just a tremendous,
a tremendous man.
Uh,
he is an actor,
writer,
director,
and producer.
His name is Jon Favreau.
I've been hugely impressed by John and we've had an opportunity to spend some
time together.
He is a man of many talents.
He burst onto the acting scene with his role in Rudy.
Then he established himself as a writer with the iconic cult hit swingers in
which you starred and many of you have seen it.
We have a lot of stories about swingers,
which I was surprised by and I had done a lot of homework.
Then Fabro made his feature film directorial debut with made,
which you also wrote and produced his other directing credits include Ironman,
Ironman to cowboys and Aliens Elf.
And that was a real turning point for him.
So we into that.
And I did not know that he was involved with Alf,
uh,
before I really dug into it as a threat.
And Chef,
which he wrote,
produced,
directed and starred in.
And the way he approached making chef was very,
very fascinating.
And as someone who's trying to create myself in more than one way,
I suppose I'm creating books and podcasts and now TV shows and I have news
coming related to that.
I was very,
very interested in how he approached doing chef,
which I fell in love with and that that's actually how I ended up connecting.
It was through chef and I went on Twitter and then we connected,
had a,
a sh a short exchange on Twitter.
And we also ended up investing in a couple of startup companies together.
Okay.
So lots of commas.
This guy does everything.
Some of his recent acting credits include the wolf of Wall Street and identity
thief and he's done much,
much more.
Uh,
he is currently directing the live action feature film that I'm dying to see
because I'm obsessed with the jungle book.
This is Disney's adaptation,
which is set to be released in April,
2016.
So without further ado,
I invite you into the mind and story,
uh,
some of which are very funny.
The stories of John [inaudible].
John,
welcome to the show.
Thank you.
Thank you so much for taking the time.
I've really been looking forward to this.
Okay.
And I suppose we could start perhaps at the beginning and one of these questions
that I like to sometimes ask is what albums or bands you listen to in high
school?
What were your go to?
What was her going to music?
Uh,
let's see.
I liked the earliest music I listened to
that I can remember actually having like an album of was I remember the animal
house soundtrack,
all the old music,
like the 60s sure.
Music.
And then,
um,
Billy Joel,
I grew up in New York,
so Billy Joel,
uh,
and my first rock album I ever bought was a,
was led Zeppelin,
was led Zeppelin.
I was in housing,
I was in high school already.
And then I was,
I was in high school in the 80s.
So then you had like the Ramones around in New York and Queens where I'm from.
So it was,
uh,
it was an interesting time.
And then I,
you know,
there's a little bit of overlap with CBGBS as I got older in high school,
but that was more for the scene because it was cool rather than the music
itself,
which I don't find myself listening to too much.
I ended up getting into Billy Joel Myself.
I was always in Metallica,
sort of heavy metal head,
and I got him to Billy Joel because I was a busboy and waited on him at 1.0
really?
On Long Island.
And he was the coolest.
Oh,
that's nice guy I'd ever met.
He would buy a cup of coffee and give me a 20 as a tip,
which was a lot of moments me at the time.
That's a big,
that's a good thing to remember.
It was a big deal either way.
Yeah,
that's,
that's pretty good.
That's not an,
you know,
in the greater scheme of things,
you could probably afford it,
but made it made a big
difference.
Look at that.
Look at each impression made you made a fan of you.
I still,
I still remember it because it's,
that gets you remember how now when a we,
we may not have the same exact frame of reference.
What are you,
um,
I'm 48 years old,
so I'm a 10 behind roughly.
I'm 37 right now.
So that was a golden oldie.
Uh,
you were listening to me old ways.
Right,
right.
I was,
he was still recording when I was,
uh,
when I was listening to him.
Yeah.
He was still,
I mean everyone there,
the hush came over all the wait staff when he came in.
Yes.
And Long Island especially kinda absolutely up in Montauk.
And the,
I remember the weeders named Gavin,
he was supposed to wait the table and he said,
all right,
I'm going to do you a favor today.
Ferris.
I'm going to give you that table because he knew you get brought out so hard.
Yeah,
exactly.
What was your experience in,
in high school?
What was it like?
Can you paint a picture?
Um,
let's see.
I was,
I had just gone to a Bronx High School of science,
which was a,
a public school that you have to take a test for in New York who's a very good
school.
It had been around for awhile and uh,
and the New York public school system,
uh,
was,
was very good at the time.
I think it still is,
if you're,
if you do well that you,
you will never outgrow this the public school system.
There's always room for people who are,
who are,
uh,
you know,
have,
who required different education needs on,
in every way.
And I know my,
my dad was a public school teacher.
Um,
and,
and you know,
I feel pretty strongly about that system and,
uh,
especially having lived in other cities too.
Uh,
I really grew to appreciate it.
And the Bronx High School of science was,
was one of the flagship schools for,
uh,
the,
is that Stuyvesant Brooklyn Tech,
uh,
you know,
all of these free schools.
Uh,
but I did have to commute all the way from Queens to the Bronx.
It was about an hour and a half each way.
But I was around other people who were more academically inclined,
but I also met people from every different borough and all different walks of
life because the,
you know,
the,
the one thing that unifies us was that we all pass this test.
Uh,
and,
and you'd have a lot of different socioeconomic backgrounds because again,
it was a free school.
And so I had the good fortune of meeting the brightest from every community to
everybody that I met.
If I'm met a kid from Harlem,
he was the,
he was a really smart kid from Harlan find myself from Brooklyn,
from Riverdale,
you know,
so you really had all walks of life.
I didn't realize it at the time cause I grew up in New York.
So diversity was just something you grew up with,
especially as you traveled through different boroughs.
You know,
you just knew people from all over the place or if you worked in the city,
you met people from everywhere.
Uh,
and,
and you know,
that was a,
I think that was a good experience too.
You learn a little bit.
I know you're,
you,
you would like to speak a lot of languages.
You get to know how to curse in every language and usually you pick up first
Greek and uh,
it,
uh,
in,
in Spanish.
And so,
but it was seeing that a lot of great kids,
but they were kind of nerdy kids.
There weren't big on sports teams,
things like that.
The long commute time,
lot of a lot of homework.
Um,
so I,
I early on the,
the first thing from high school that I got into through that crowd was dungeons
and dragons.
That was something I was really into a then I kind of outgrew that a bit more
socially than anything.
But I always like fantasy.
I always liked that swords and sorcery stuff and science fiction.
And then it,
then I moved more into,
cause remember I graduated in 84,
so it was the early eighties.
That's when also punk rock was,
was kind of in its heyday and,
and there were a lot of clubs downtown that we're going strong that you could go
to.
So,
and,
and we were from all the different boroughs.
So we very comfortable going into Manhattan.
That was kind of the central point for this was still in high school,
still in high school.
Um,
never really was,
uh,
the,
the kids from the city,
from Manhattan.
We're more the,
a little bit more socially advanced and can actually get into these year.
Yeah.
You know,
we're,
we're from the,
you know,
we're the bridge and tunnel crowd,
so we didn't really end up in the nightlife too much.
Uh,
but,
but you were exposed to it and you were going down to Greenwich village and
hanging out in Washington square park and,
and,
and also that was a lot of when I got introduced to cinema because it was pre
VCR.
Uh,
the only way you'd see a movie as it was in a movie theater if it was on
television.
And so I remember going to a lot of the revival houses first with my dad when I
was younger and then,
and then,
you know,
when I was in high school going on my own down to like the cinema village,
uh,
all around,
all around Nyu down there,
there were a lot of great revival houses and seeing the films of like Kurosawa
Scorsese and,
um,
just being introduced to a lot of stuff I would not otherwise have access to.
Was there any particular film that was the inflection point for you wanting to
focus on that craft herself?
I didn't want to do it till much later.
It was never a realistic option for me.
So all the way through high school,
college,
it was never something that I thought I would do.
It wasn't until I was 22 that I actually decided to try and earnest to,
to get into entertainment,
but I always enjoyed acting and I would love movies.
Uh,
and I was an usher actually during high school at an old,
uh,
x Vaudeville House,
the Rko,
Keith's and flushing.
And,
and as,
uh,
as an usher,
you got to see movies over and over again.
And it was still the architecture,
the projection room,
all of it really felt like something out of a time machine.
So I was exposed to that side of the movie business first.
And,
uh,
and it was,
you know,
it was really cool.
I liked it.
I like movies.
It was an old rundown theater.
It's not there anymore.
Uh,
but it was really wonderful seeing the kind of could see the history of it if
you look behind the curtain,
because first it was an old Vaudeville palace and then it started showing films
and then,
and then eventually it got broken up into a triplex.
So you had this beautiful,
elegant,
Morrish style,
uh,
just,
you know,
again,
the movie palaces of,
of,
of the,
of the Vaudeville era and the postwar Avalara,
uh,
broken down into the multiplexes that didn't have a lot of personality back in
the,
in the 80s,
I guess the 70s started that.
But it still had some of the gloss of it and some of the beauty and,
but you know,
of course they were still the dressing rooms from the Vaudeville days and there
were sub basements and he went behind the screen and the big theater and you
saw,
you know,
all the ropes and rigging from it's,
it's live theater days.
So it was Kinda,
it was Kinda nice and there was a sense of nostalgia,
but it was also just overrun by mice and it wasn't just,
it wasn't well maintained.
So there was a sadness to it.
So those I haven't nostalgic field towards the movie business even from,
you know,
even from before I was around because I was exposed to all that stuff.
And of course all the movies keep,
keep the legacy alive as well.
And,
and that was part of the fun part about coming out here.
Even when I was just auditioning for the first time,
for forbid parts you would audition on the lot,
you would go,
you'd get a drive on and then you'd be walking around like the Fox lot and see
the New York streets or Warner brothers and see all the backlots as you're
walking from your parking to the appointment and you just felt so lucky to be in
the business,
you know,
you were like,
um,
you know,
somehow connected to this industry.
And even though we were just like the guy sweeping up after the parade,
we still were,
you know,
what,
give up show Biz,
you know,
even the guy shoveling after the elephant,
it feels like he's part of the show.
And I,
and I was that guy.
And you uh,
you dropped out of college,
is that right?
I did,
yeah.
It was well a misleading cause I took a,
I took a,
you took to go to,
I got a job offer,
we got a job offer to work on Wall Street.
Got It.
For our friend's dad who need to hire an assistant.
And I worked there for a year and a,
it wasn't a great fit for me,
but I had not been a great student in college.
I had gone to a very academically oriented high school as I said.
And then I was on the waiting list for Cooper Union to go to school for
engineering.
Cooper Union is a great school in Greenwich Village that is,
uh,
it's all scholarship.
It would have been a great,
would have been a great fit for me.
And again,
my family was,
you know,
my,
my dad was a teacher,
so there wasn't a lot.
We have a lot of dough for a private education,
but the idea of Cooper Union,
I would've gotten a great,
a great opportunity,
a waiting list,
never got called up.
I ended up going to Queens College,
which was a city school,
good school too.
Um,
and,
but never really found my footing.
What I wanted to do was more interested in the,
uh,
what was going on socially at school rather than academically.
I didn't really have a major,
I didn't find myself excelling.
I got by,
but um,
but I didn't excel.
And then after I'd worked for a year and went back to school,
then I got dean's list,
straight A's because that,
that year of working in the real
world really a seasoned me a bit.
And,
and I got me a,
I think matured me a bit.
And then,
and then after I was back in school and back on the Dean's list,
that's when I went cross country and that's when I discovered,
uh,
people doing improvisation in Chicago and decided I wanted to join that circus
and that's when I dropped out.
Got It.
And the,
when you came back and were more seasoned and hit the Dean's list,
was that because of the structure of working in the adult world or was it
because you saw the benefits of focus rewarded and say,
uh,
accompany or uh,
well,
kind of the opposite of that.
I felt that,
that you,
you,
it at school,
if you worked at all,
you got it,
you got recognized.
There's every once in a while an asshole teacher that,
uh,
you know,
busting my ass and the guy's still giving me bad grades.
Like,
but that's like a rarity usually if you are working,
usually if you're not doing good in school,
you don't like the teacher.
You're not,
you're not coming halfway,
you're not doing your job.
But if you do your work,
you'll get an a and there's something real,
you know,
really gala Terrian about that.
Whereas in the workspace you,
you're expected to bust your ass and rarely do you get recognized for the work
you do because somebody else's,
either they are either oblivious because they're so hung up on what they're
dealing with,
your boss or somebody else's,
the the,
you know,
there's weird office politics or your just,
it's just expected of you to do your work.
So it,
it felt like a,
a whiff of reality of the real world where it's not revolving around you.
Whereas in school,
even if you're part of a big lecture hall,
at the end of the day it's about you.
You're the,
you're paying money to be there,
they're going to give you a grade based on the work you do.
And it's focused around how you absorb and fit the work and how you fit into the
system.
In the workplace workspace,
you're a cog and you can figure out how to move your way up,
but it's not incumbent upon them to recognize you.
You have to make your own way.
So it felt like a very,
a much,
it felt like I was going back to a kinder,
gentler situation when I went back to school where I put in the same work I
would have,
uh,
at,
you know,
on Wall Street.
And then I was getting straight A's.
So it felt good,
but I also felt in,
in another way that it let some of the air out of the balloon that I got a whiff
of what real life was,
what was waiting in the wings.
It was kind of scary that it was like,
okay,
now I'm going to work 50 weeks a year to get two weeks off and I'm going to live
in those two weeks because pretty much everything happening during the week,
year,
either recovering over the weekends or your or your or your,
you know,
you just,
everything's about getting ready for work.
I just came home from work,
uh,
decompressing and just getting back on the horse the next day.
And especially in Manhattan where you're,
you know,
I was commuting from the boroughs also.
Um,
and,
and then I had gone cross country and seeing how everybody was living and I had
what sparked that cross country trip.
I think it was,
I think it was that I had worked for a year.
Right.
Um,
and I'd save up enough money for a motorcycle and that was sort of a fantasy to
go.
Yeah.
You watched like easy,
easy rider.
Why did,
that's the thing.
Oh man,
you know.
Uh,
and so I went cross country and I was,
there was a,
a motorcycle rally in Sturgis,
South Dakota that happened to be lining up with when I wasn't in school or
something.
I don't even remember.
I was still,
it was in school,
it's going back many years now in the 80s.
But I remember saying,
Oh,
let me go check this out.
And then once I was all the way in South Dakota,
I'm a girl I was dating at the time,
was in San Francisco and I,
it looked close on the map and I was like,
let me just hear like it's only three and a half inches.
I'll never be closer.
Um,
and that's back when I was just thinking about the other day,
it was back before you could just go online and get a map.
Like you had to belong to like the AAA and trip tick something where they would
send you maps with highlighters,
showing you the roots.
So you had this map that was like folded up and your in your,
in your saddlebag and you would look at it.
It really was like the old west.
And,
you know,
you're like a,
an on horseback going cross country.
And it was such a long harrowing trip.
And I remember how many people in the country look like they weren't enjoying
themselves the way they live the way.
And some people were having a great time,
but like there's,
there seem to be a lot of,
um,
variety in the way people lived and the lifestyles people had.
And I think also having grown up in a big city,
I didn't realize what,
what rural America was like and really how big the country was and how,
how much variety there was.
And,
and also the other thing was how,
how,
uh,
personable people are.
And I,
you know,
here I was on a motorcycle.
Well,
I was young and I wasn't,
you know,
I,
I was not user friendly.
I didn't have the,
you know,
Buckminster Fuller banker,
look,
I was,
you know,
a guy climbing all covered with dust and young and New York plates on my bike.
And,
and people were really cool to me.
Like people really,
when if I broke down,
people help me out.
I helped other people out.
You know,
you sort of develop a sense of how you fit into the world and how it's not about
you.
You're one little piece of the whole thing and you start to appreciate how big
the world is and that you have to figure out how to fit into that.
Whereas I think your whole life,
especially where I was brought up,
it's more about how does it fit into my world.
So it's that perspective that,
you know,
I think we all continue to struggle with as we get older.
How we fit into this whole thing,
how this whole,
it's not fair.
Okay.
Feeling is,
is one that you feel a lot more when you're young and when you're older there's
something magical that motorcycles to being part of the environment as opposed
to inside the bubble that is the chassis of the car would not recommend it by
the way.
Very dangerous.
I W W I'm not,
my buddy is in a wheelchair now who introduced me to it.
Uh,
it's,
it,
it fits in really well with your sense of invulnerability that comes at that
age.
Uh,
not something I,
I would do.
I would thought if I could afford,
when I would,
so let me just say to the people listening out there,
I don't want to turn this into something where a proselytizing for it because
it's not,
it's not something that I do anymore,
but it,
but it was definitely a,
a bit of a,
a transcendent experience that you're flying and you're,
you are so vulnerable and so much,
uh,
you know,
they're there.
You're just,
you're just taking it in,
in a much different way.
It's,
it's,
it's like a ride.
So I'm going to love to ask you about Chicago,
uh,
motorcycle.
Also,
just as a side note for folks,
I totaled the bike and at that point sold it because I had a friend,
gets a fantastic writer,
had a car,
run a red light,
hit him at an intersection,
cutoff one of his legs and a,
when your body is the bumper,
my mom actually calls motorcycles donor cycles because she's been a PT for his
30 plus years in injuries with perfect organs.
So,
uh,
and it's not the,
it's not the writer,
it's the people around you and,
and,
um,
and under the right circumstances it's great.
But the way I'm very fortunate that,
that I made it out,
uh,
intact because it's,
it's,
um,
bad odds.
You plant your plant,
your plants slots at the,
it's not,
it's not the best game.
That has nothing to do with how good you are as a writer,
like you said.
So dialing back the clock a little ways.
So,
and I won't spend too much time on this,
but I was a runner up until about sixth grade,
got the living hell beat out of me all the time and d and d was my refuge.
So I still have all of my modules.
Um,
I'm one of those guys.
Uh,
now I'm completely self conscious about the fact that I played.
It's like,
it takes a lot for me to talk freely like this about it,
but I feel like weird shame.
Why reason?
Why do you feel shame about it?
I don't know.
I feel this,
I kind of wear it as a badge of honor in a way because I run into so many people
who,
who also had that shared experience.
Well,
I think I've grown into it like I think I'm accepting of it now,
but it was such a way I had been deaf,
defined myself for the first few years,
like for like a freshman and sophomore year in high school.
And that was like,
what?
And then when I didn't do it anymore.
You're so quick to say why,
because I find that there's nothing more embarrassing than whatever the last
phase you just went through was,
I continue to feel that way.
Yeah.
You know,
thank God my life is not,
you know,
all the things that you have,
ways you embarrass yourself,
all the haircuts you've had,
the ways that you've addressed the music you listened to.
I used to have a rat tail.
Exactly.
Years and now I'm of the age where,
you know,
for,
for the,
the children's generation of this age,
that's all going to be well documented and very hard to escape.
Right.
Uh,
every single Facebook,
you know,
picture you put up will be there on some level.
Uh,
so,
but,
uh,
but I,
you know,
you're right.
I think that there was,
um,
tremendous value in it.
I have an affection for it.
I remember too much of it.
Um,
you know,
it really took up a lot of my brain space,
uh,
when I was,
when I was around that age,
whatever,
15 or 14,
I forget what age I was playing.
Um,
but it also created
a set of skills,
I think.
I think it encouraged a set of skills that is not that on like,
um,
a filmmaking because you're telling a story and the people who are experiencing
that story,
especially if you're like a dungeon master,
you're telling the story in a way that,
um,
where the people who are participating,
who've signed on are experiencing in a very subjective way,
and there appears to be a certain level of spontaneity or freewill and there is
built into it.
But you're creating a context in a world and experience that's very,
uh,
specifically curated.
So you're guaranteeing a sort of experience regardless of what they do within
it.
And I think when you're watching movies,
the,
um,
the illusion is that your,
you,
you're,
you're subjectively experiencing the film as an individual and your kind of
making those decisions in a defacto way through the character that you're
following the film through.
If a character in a film ever makes a decision that the audience doesn't feel
that they agree with it,
it changes the experience.
It becomes like a horror movie where don't go in that room,
you know,
it becomes a much different type of experience.
Or you're,
or if you're watching a character that's,
um,
that's not,
you know,
that you're watching because they're,
they're an anti hero.
You know,
when you're watching Travis Bickle is,
is a different experience than most films because most films,
you're going to walk through it,
experience the things that the characters do.
They're going to do a smarter version.
Usually if something you would have done and they're going to be facing a lot of
consequences and you're rooting for them because you and them or kind of writing
next year you're,
you're the copilot of the,
of the protagonist.
And in role playing games,
it's a similar experience but,
but a different medium.
Were you,
did you have a particular,
a race of preference where you a dwarf I uh,
on alcohol,
those I didn't like the l so much.
I liked the dwarves,
like the hobbits.
I was always a grail.
That makes sense for you.
I don't remember what's the gray is a great difference.
I just,
I like the wood ones.
Yeah.
They're also dro.
I think the Dro Elf,
those were the dark elves,
the dark ones.
They were the,
I remember more from the Tolkien stuff.
Now it's sort of replaced it because I was in grade eight.
They do blend together.
We do well,
yeah,
we're very close.
But I liked the hobbits cause I read the book,
the Hobbit,
and before I ever played
the game,
it was an important book to me.
And I always liked,
I kind of relate to the,
to,
to that character because he just wants to be comfortable and living in like the
nice environment,
but then has drawn out into the adventure and then returns.
It's very Joseph Campbell,
um,
that,
that reluctant hero.
And I think that that's a good metaphor for what I've experienced.
Is that the,
you know,
I've never jumped into the stuff,
uh,
you know,
I guess I guess it may be there's been a little bit of boredom or unrest and
earlier in my life,
but,
but generally I kind of like,
I like some kind of things kind of boring,
but then every once in a while I just,
there's a little bit of that,
that adventure blood in me that forces me out of it.
I think we're different people from reading,
knowing you have more self preservation instinct I think is worth complacency or
something.
But I do it kind of in spite of who I am as opposed to,
because I'm,
I have this wanderlust and I,
and I can't sit still.
I just get bored sometimes and I want variety or I get,
um,
something,
uh,
captures my fancy and I get really curious and want to try something new.
Uh,
I'm an only child.
I tend to do it more for me,
I find than to show other people.
I tend to be very,
what does the itch that you're scratching would that,
that,
that novelty satisfies,
do you think?
Oh,
no.
You know,
uh,
I think it's different as I get older because now it becomes about what
impressions I had from younger in life and things,
you know,
on that checklist of,
how people buy the car that they never could afford.
Sure.
Later.
Or they,
you know,
where they date the girl they couldn't date.
You know,
there's a sense of,
of,
uh,
somehow,
you know,
working on your scorecard.
But for me it's like,
um,
like I want,
as I get older,
especially,
it's like I wanted to try to sculpt and I,
and I started scrolling literally.
Yeah.
Literally like sculpting.
And I'm lucky that I work with such talented people of all different diverse
skillsets in the movie business.
Then when I want to sculpt,
I talked to somebody who's an expert sculptor,
sculptor,
and they,
and they put together a little package from me of an analyst of tools I need.
And,
and next thing you know,
without a lot of wasted time,
um,
I'm sculpting,
I always drew.
Yeah.
And I always would sculpt a little bit here and there,
whatever,
if I was in like a class or playing with the kids play Doh and daddy was always
good at,
at,
at making simplest step aside kid,
I wish I had done a lot of,
you get a lot of,
you know,
when you go to parent teacher day or whatever,
the kids would bring that to school,
whatever that thing is.
When daddy could make something cool out of playdough you get,
you get,
you know,
restrict around the street cred.
Yeah.
So what material were you or are you using on now?
Chavon something called a shuttle launch is one of those.
Um,
I think it's petroleum based or wax based,
uh,
clays that doesn't dry and um,
you have to heat up to get it.
You get these little blocks that look kind of like plastic explosives,
I guess.
Kinda,
I know what you're talking about.
Yeah.
And uh,
it was developed I think for the automotive industry,
so you get some really nice textures out of it and uh,
it's just fun to do because you,
you're doing better than you thought.
You could know why sculpture as opposed to I want it to be a comic book.
Penciler for about 10 years.
A lot of illustration.
Why,
uh,
why sculpture as opposed to something else?
Like water colors or,
oh,
I don't know.
There's something fun.
I did it
because you could,
uh,
give it to people.
Yeah.
Okay.
It's like a thing,
it's like a substantial thing that you have or you could display or you could
give or,
or cast into a metal or,
I don't know.
It just seemed kind of cool.
Uh,
I was,
I was messing around on the,
on the set of jungle book with a,
we had blocks of wax because there's a sequence where that we have a beat,
big beehives that we had to cast and we had to cast it out of whack so it
interacted in a way that was realistic.
And so we had blocks and blocks of bees wax around.
And so while I was on the set,
on the many hours sitting at the,
in the director's chair,
I had a block of wax sitting there for about a month.
And then next thing you know,
I,
I asked for something to carve it with it,
it carve it with,
and I got like some little carving tools and next thing you know,
I was carving a bear.
And next thing you know,
it's like I pull over the,
all these artists that are working on that.
So,
well,
what's,
how should I do?
Well,
the bear,
the ears are a little far back.
Move this a little fun.
And so I was getting pointers in everybody who had passed by.
Oh,
it looks like a bear.
Yeah,
it's um,
a little bit of what a good boy am I and something have to see at this age.
Honestly,
it's like,
um,
I'm very happy to be working in the field than I am.
I feel like I'm learning constantly,
but I understand why.
I think like nick naulty I heard like loves glassblowing.
Like I get it.
I get why that's exactly the type of thing to be doing.
And I did actually,
my experience was with cooking with you.
I've read your book,
by the way.
I know we've told you this,
but let me tell you this on the,
I appreciate it.
That task,
uh,
the f four hour chef,
when I was preparing to do chef,
uh,
I always liked watching,
which blew my mind.
I've said,
it's you and I've said it's on the Internet,
but I'm,
we're going to dig into that.
Okay.
But we lovely moving.
Thank you.
It was a great movie and important film for me cause it,
it,
it just,
you know,
it allowed me to deal with themes that I felt were important,
but,
but also it gave me the excuse to learn from great chefs and work in the
kitchens of great chefs to prepare for the acting in,
in,
in the film.
And I loved cooking and I loved,
and I never,
Roy Choi the,
the,
the chef who really was,
was my partner in this,
um,
as he was preparing me when,
when we first started,
he said,
you'll,
you'll a chef when a shop,
because he's telling me these things to teach me,
but also to understand insight as I told the story to make the film one that he
and the community would like.
He said,
when a chef sees a bag of shallots,
they get excited because they're going to get to peel all the shallots and,
and,
um,
which I thought was,
it was confusing at first.
But then after going through the culinary training and everything,
there's some,
it's true.
There's something very meditative about preparing your meals.
And plus because you,
you're dealing with sharp implements and you have to get it perfect and you
can't hurt yourself and you can't really do anything but this thing.
But it doesn't require all of your brain at the same time.
And so you get into this really cool zone where you,
everything so thoughtful that you're doing,
and by the time you actually prepare a meal with all of this means that you
prepare,
that you,
that you get ready.
There's a tendency to be very tuned into what you're tasting or what you're
presenting to your guests because they know the work they've been watching.
You put work into it.
And so the mindfulness,
uh,
that it implies and,
and,
and demands and its preparation,
but it also asks of the people,
um,
who,
who you're sharing it with.
Uh,
it,
it creates a,
um,
a nexus point of all the people where you're all sharing a common experience at
one moment,
which,
uh,
is something I've grown to appreciate and,
and is a very elusive dynamic as,
as a dad.
It's,
it's very,
you know,
being very,
very present as,
as you,
um,
you know,
spend time with your kids,
making sure you're not checking your emails when you're tucking the kids in.
You know,
it's,
and,
and with friends and,
and as a husband there's a,
it's not something I did effortlessly a decade ago and it's something that I've
grown into and I find that people as they mature,
they start to value that more.
And so everything that I looked to do,
whether it's sculpture or,
you know,
I would be a glass blower.
I would love to play with that.
It seems fascinating or,
uh,
you know,
any of these hobby type things for the cooking is all about being very present
in that moment.
And,
um,
and it's a good,
it's a good counterbalance to the intensity with which I approached my,
the work
that I do.
I think the,
the word mindfulness is so appropriate for cooking.
And I found the what used to create so much stress,
a such a stretch responds to me,
which was preparing food is now become,
like you said,
almost this meditative practice where I could meditate in the mornings and I
tend to do that.
But I also find that if I just make food,
make dinner two or three times a week and you have these knives,
so you have to be present,
state aware.
It's,
it has a tremendous decompressing effect.
Um,
are there any particular ingredients that you're playing with these days or
anything?
Ever since I made chef and met Aaron Franklin down in Austin,
I've been over and over again refining,
uh,
my smoke brisket,
the central Texas south smoked brisket.
And to me that's like alchemy.
You know,
it's,
there's tea,
there's a certain amount of technique and the trimming and in the way you that,
but mostly it's about leaving it alone.
It's almost like baking in that way.
Like it's,
it's,
it's chemistry and changing little factors,
but it's taking whatever it is,
14 hours to see how it turns out.
There's something really rewarding about that.
And it's also a flavor that people don't get anywhere else.
So when you do it right and people get to taste it,
it's,
it's kind of a fun,
it's kind of a fun thing to share because it's special and it's only,
it's only good for a short amount of time to,
yeah,
it's,
you know,
it's like a coffee and then it kind of goes away.
Uh,
and then I like that.
I like,
um,
simple pasta dishes,
very simple ones.
You know,
like there's a,
there's a pasta Scarpetta the restaurant Scarpetta mics are really good pasta.
That's just in a tomato sauce that you could find online the recipe for.
But,
but making the pasta from scratch,
infusing the oil,
uh,
starting the tomato sauce from Roma tomatoes that you blanch and peel and slow
cook and mashed down into a sauce and then mixing it with the infused olive oil
and then cooking that with the pasta water and getting the right texture.
And again,
it's amazing,
but it's only good for just a few minutes.
And,
and then,
and there with the pasta dishes is great cause you,
you pulled together a group of people who are interested in doing it.
It's a great thing to do.
Uh,
if the family's all vacation someplace or you're over at a relative's house,
especially because I have less and less things to talk about.
Cause my,
my context is so different from everybody else's that,
you know,
if we talk about movies it's not,
I'm,
I'm thinking about other things than the people talking to me.
We're thinking about,
uh,
and you know,
it's,
there's so little overlap with most people that I meet that cooking is great
because it creates this context where everybody is on equal footing and
everybody has a different skillset and it becomes a real,
a,
a task that you have to be,
you're interdependent with.
And,
and it,
it,
I find I have an endless patience to spend time with people that I don't know
very well if you're working on a really exciting cooking project.
And then at the end we all serve it together and we really feel like we fought a
war together.
Oh,
it's a,
it's a great,
it's a great bonding thing.
I'm working on a kitchen at my and my house that's geared towards having like
groups of people cook that feels more like a restaurant style.
Big Table tops.
Yeah.
On all like open shelving and you know,
everything that you'd see,
you know,
beautiful in a way of restaurants.
Beautiful.
Not Beautiful for a house,
but,
uh,
the people who like to cook,
it's like the perfect,
like a,
like a lab and uh,
it's,
it's fun because you know,
you're all gathered around and,
and uh,
uh,
I did it.
My experience,
I,
the first time I did it like that was at the,
uh,
at the Skywalker ranch,
which is where we,
we mix the sound for a few movies.
I've been working with them I think since ironman.
Uh,
but for those of you who don't know,
it's,
it's a,
it's a 5,000 Acre ranch,
uh,
in northern California,
in,
in Morin that George Lucas,
uh,
put together and,
and,
and oversaw the architecture for.
And it's a started off as just a sound facility.
Very high.
It's very,
it looks very low tech.
It looks like a winery almost,
but beautiful.
Rolling hills with cattle grazing,
a Victorian House on the hill that he's,
where he does his editing and where he,
he,
he uses his own base and other technical buildings that have cropped up around
it.
And it's state of the art mixing facility.
Sound facility are recording stages.
Um,
so it's this very strange and in a bunk house,
uh,
with themed rooms for the people who,
who work there because you,
you stay there when you work there because it's so remote.
And so each,
a room is themed for either a director or a writer and a,
so you have like the John Ford Room,
that's western theme,
the Akira Kurosawa Room,
Dorothy Parker Room.
And so you stay there and during the day there are restaurants that are open on
the facility at night.
Everything closes down,
but there's a commercial kitchen in the common area and a walk in a walk in
fridge.
And so as we were making chef,
you know,
you're looking at these scenes over and over again,
listening to the crackling of the,
you know,
the frying food and the pasta and the olive oil and the,
the,
the garlic simmering and your,
your mouth watering all day.
And each night we would pick another,
a recipe from the movie and all of us,
me and the editors,
the sound crew,
uh,
we'd all get together and we cook together at night and we cook all the dishes
from the movie.
And it was so much fun,
uh,
because here we're in the middle of,
you know,
in the middle of nowhere,
really in a very remote spot.
And,
and just together,
you know,
the fireplace gone,
all of us cooking together and he'd sit down for the meal and you sleep good.
And then we hit it the next morning and we would do the next real,
I like a hell of a hell of a routine that he was amazing.
It was really wonderful.
So that's what I want to try to see if I could capture some of that at home.
Yeah.
The,
uh,
the,
the one thing that's always struck me about a well designed kitchen,
it's just the elegance and the economy of movement that it provides for a chef.
A where they're,
they're,
they're never reaching too far for anything.
Everything.
I mean,
you have everything in its place or at the meet some plastic.
Right.
And how quickly a good line cook or chef can work if they have all their items
in the right place.
Yeah,
it's true.
It's,
uh,
it's interesting because I did it.
Part of the training I did was working first.
First I went to some pretty accelerated culinary training that Roy sent me to
off with a French chef,
uh,
to get a context before I ever entered a professional kitchen.
And so I went through all my mother sauces,
my knife cuts,
and basically an overview of what the first year culinary students would deal
with.
Then I got to come into his kitchen.
He has a few different restaurants and food trucks too.
And I spent time a floating from restaurant to restaurant first they let me like
prep cook.
So I was picking Parsley.
You know what I mean?
I've done that.
Micro Basil.
Yeah.
They're like your whole number station.
Ferris.
I'm like,
Oh God.
Because it's all about trust you with and it's so like labor intensive.
And so you finally do that.
And then,
uh,
then eventually I worked my way up to the hotline and on the hotline.
Then I started working and then,
and then I worked the pretty,
but midway through I started working on one of his Kogi trucks and it reminded
me,
cause there you're in tight quarters to you reminded me very much a bartending,
which is what I did,
uh,
to make a living,
in college and after college when I moved to Chicago as a bartender.
And you know,
there's that dynamic of,
of getting in the weeds.
It's kind of halfway between being a chef and being,
uh,
a server because you're preparing things,
but you're also dealing with the public and you're not doing anything that
complicated.
So you don't have the,
um,
there's not the elegance of,
of being a chef,
at least the type of bartender I was.
I wasn't like a mixologist.
Uh,
like you see now,
but uh,
but there is this,
you do get into the weeds and you have to do this dance with the people in a
very small space.
And I found that that rhythm was coming back to me as I was working,
especially on that truck.
We know how to get out of the way.
You pop in,
you pop out,
you reach around,
uh,
on somebody who's left on there,
right?
You're behind them,
you're not crashing into each other and you're helping each other out and you
become like this big octopus together.
And when you're working on the hotline,
it's even more that way because there's,
you know,
behind you,
there's like hot food coming through.
People are speaking different languages.
You're,
um,
you're being asked to do things,
you're being instructed to.
That's the other weird thing.
It's not like they prepare you ahead of time and say,
here's how you make everything.
Let's train.
Maybe when you first open a restaurant,
it's that way.
But when you're working in a,
in an established kitchen,
they basically just throw you on the line and then the rush comes and then they
show you once how to do something and then you just copy them and maybe they
show it to you again.
And then the chefs watching you from a distance and saying,
hey,
you only put Mayo on one side of the bond that goes on both,
you know,
there's a certain quality control aspect that the chefs,
that's really what the chef's job is,
is overseeing other people doing the work and keeping the standards to a certain
consistency.
And so there was,
you know,
working and little by little,
first it's,
I'm just doing the popcorn at a frame and then then I'm next seen on pulling the
burgers out or doing the,
you know,
assembling some sandwiches and next thing you know,
and plating.
And so by the end of the Saturday dinner rush,
you know,
there's a half dozen played,
some helping with and you start to appreciate how good these other people are.
You know,
the people who work the broiler or the Saute Cook,
you know who the grill station is,
just nailing them.
You know,
it was making it perfect and timing it just right.
And then,
and then the one that I remarked at the most was the,
was the,
was the bus boy who knows,
just went to walk up to you with that,
with that Deli container full of ice water and like that's the best water you've
ever had.
Like I didn't even know I was thirsty.
And then this guy hands me this like 16 hours,
you know,
the court size,
like you'd get wonton soup in that clear container.
So those are all over kitchens,
right?
Those,
the Deli containers and they,
they'll give you one full ice water and you'll drink it in like one sip and it's
the best thing you've ever had in your life.
And,
um,
and as I was mentioning that to Roy,
he says,
yeah,
you're ready to make the movie.
That's not how you found that,
that experience is what,
how,
I know you're ready.
So speaking of,
of moments,
uh,
when did you decide to write chef?
I'd love to talk a little bit about the writing process.
Chef chef was okay,
now remember,
I,
you know,
it's Kinda hard out of context with,
with what the swingers experience was kind of weaker.
Well,
let's talk about both what swingers it was,
um,
that I had,
I had not known I was going to be a writer.
I had received from my dad,
uh,
um,
final draft,
which was a program that is pretty user friendly and formats you're writing to
look like a screenplay.
And,
and,
and for people who are writers or want to be writers,
a lot of it is,
um,
there are subtle things that once like a,
let's say a job like a resume for a job,
there are certain standards by how you're going to put that together so that
when somebody receives that resume,
it looks professional.
The formatting,
the formatting,
all that stuff.
I don't know that much about just regular jobs,
but,
but I know like a lot of effort goes into the resume,
a headshot for an actor for a screenplay.
As people received the script,
they're making a lot of little subconscious calculations and decisions about you
based on what they're seeing.
And,
uh,
the screenplay that's not formatted properly is something that's completely
dismissed.
Uh,
and what was fun was when I received the program,
I just typed a little bit.
Next thing I know,
it looked just like a real screenplay and I've read enough of them for being an
actor.
And this was after I had already done Rudy.
I had moved to Los Angeles.
I thought that was going to be my big break,
but things weren't really popping for me.
But I had read enough scripts and knew enough about acting to um,
feel comfortable tapping away the screenplay.
Never thinking it was going to,
anything was gonna happen with it more to show my friends and you know,
you type,
you type for half hour an hour,
two hours,
next thing you know you've got like a stack of eight pages and it feels like
you've got a piece of a screenplay there.
And so then it becomes like,
I just want to try this.
You know,
it kind of goes back to the earlier conversation we're having about why,
why do you,
why do you do things,
you know,
uh,
for you,
it's that you can't sit still and you're,
it's part of it and you're super curious and you've got a lot of energy and you,
you kind of hunger for it.
I think with me it's,
it's,
it's a little bit more erratic than
that where I just get,
I just get some bites me in the ass and I want to try something.
Like I'm just curious about something if I could do something,
but it's,
um,
it's much subtler and I just tap away at it and peck away at it and then it
starts to look good.
And as it looks better,
you start to build up.
Um,
like with doing sculpture,
like messing around a little bit.
Next thing you know,
it kind of looks like a bear.
Well let me carve it a little bit better.
Let me try a little bit more.
Let's see how far I could take this thing.
And,
and so with the screenplay,
it was kind of like that and uh,
showed it,
some friends
showed it to the acting agent.
I had people felt good about the swingers screenplay and then we,
how long did it take you to get it to a first draft?
Let's just say very fast because there was no pressure.
I didn't have any an have any,
I wouldn't,
I would outline maybe a few pages ahead of where I was.
I came from an Improv background from Chicago,
so it was really just characters talking to each other.
The improv that I did was something called the Herald,
which was a del close.
It invented,
it was a great improv teacher and she'll herald the herald like the name.
Okay.
Got It.
And it was one of those things like what do you call it,
Harold?
You know,
it was one of those,
that's how it got its name.
I like the Beatles haircut.
I think I got it.
Had a name,
I forget what the name was.
Uh,
but,
but there's uh,
it's long form.
So you would start off and take one suggestion and do three different scenes
with different characters that were unrelated,
all inspired by this one suggestion.
And then you would have three beats of those scenes and by the end they would
all interweave and connect and come to some greater statement about the,
the um,
the suggestion.
Then just a short form joke,
uh,
oriented improvisational skit wood.
So it's looking to bring Improv into revealing it as a higher form to reveal
greater truths about,
about the suggestion by forming group mind with a,
a team of improvisors who are used to working with one another.
And that was the aspiration for that.
But it did give me a,
a set of skills.
Having done that in Chicago for a while,
that you know,
your self editing,
your,
you knowing what each scene should end,
you're bringing the next scene to begin,
maybe after some time has passed or with a plot point that had occurred.
And you know,
you're,
you're learning story,
the hardware you're learning story in front of a bar full of people who paid $4
to be in there and they want to be entertained and laugh.
But the laughter doesn't last if there's no story stories,
the king and you know,
you think it's about the last.
But really it's about investing in the story being drawn in.
And um,
and so I,
I guess I had enough skills from that and also read enough screenplays and maybe
the dungeon and dragons and stuff,
storyteller,
knowing how to create a little bit of a world that,
uh,
you know,
here,
here I was,
uh,
unfolding the story about this group of friends in Hollywood,
a set in the same world.
I lived in a,
I had broken up or have been broken up with at the time about a year earlier.
So I was still,
that was fresh in my mind.
So that was one of the characters,
dilemmas.
And although it wasn't really a autobiographical,
there were enough things that I could draw from.
You know,
what's the expression from Glengarry Glen Ross?
Always tell the truth.
That's the easiest thing to remember.
Yeah.
Draw upon,
you know,
if you're gonna talk about neighborhood,
talking about the neighborhood you grew up and talk about the neighborhood,
you know,
even if it's not you,
but you're going to have a more consistent world that you're developing,
then if you're putting them on Mars and you don't understand Mars.
Uh,
so,
you know,
a lot of things got slugged in and,
and I wrote it,
um,
pretty fairly quickly,
about two weeks,
two weeks.
He was very quick.
And it didn't change really that much after that did not change.
It did not.
But I had,
remember I had written my sketches and things.
Did you write it?
Start to,
do you read it?
You wrote it from the beginning to the end of the beginning of the end,
if you think's changed?
Not much.
10%.
Got It over time.
Um,
and that was in final draft.
Yeah.
It was a good,
was shut at the same way that did it start to finish.
So chef,
I didn't,
you know,
I'd written made after that few years later and then I had been hired as a
writer based on swingers to do script doctoring and things.
And that's where it gets tough because when you start getting paid to do
something that used to do for fun,
you don't want to do it for fun as much.
And,
and um,
what was nice about it is that you can,
you can make a living enough to,
you know,
for a single dude to be able to buy a house over a few years and you know,
drive a new car,
you know,
or newish car but you can make a living just being a writer for hire because
they're always looking for people with fresh takes and new ideas in the writing
area.
Cause the very established writers are all,
you know,
they're busy.
You know,
you get hired to do one thing that could keep you busy for a year.
So there's always room for another rider.
Once you kind of make that list,
uh,
unfortunate.
If you're not on the list,
you can't get an a door and swingers put you on the list.
Swingers put me on that list.
So I went from an actor and also people kind of knew me from my acting from
Rooney.
And so there's a bit of a novelty of being an actor that they recognize and know
when you're already used to being in those rooms.
You're already,
people know who you are,
you knew who they are,
you already have representation.
So it's easier to get into that system.
So,
uh,
that was uh,
a bit of a,
I wouldn't say it's a life hack but uh,
but it's um,
my using that term properly I think and know,
I think,
I think that a,
you kind of sound like I fit on your podcast here.
Oh,
you're already fit on the podcast.
You're doing great.
The,
I think the uh,
the f it seems like you gave yourself sort of more tickets in the raffle,
so to speak,
than a lot of people get,
cause you had the writing,
acting,
directing.
Well,
irons in the fire.
Not,
not all necessarily,
that's not financially,
but in the beginning,
remember,
I'm trying to break into another field,
right?
Right.
So I'm like seeing how far I could take this thing and the acting thing got me
more raffle tickets in that sense.
Um,
but it was an interesting way into writing and much like how acting was a really
interesting way into directing because in directing,
one of the disadvantages that most people other than me had was that if you're
going to direct,
the only way you can show people,
your director is by directing.
There's no apprenticeship per se and directing,
it's not like assistant directors.
There's an apprenticeship.
You could work your way up from way up from a PA,
work your way up to second,
second,
second a d two first aid.
You will hit the top of the food chain in and by learning from other people who
are better than you,
there's no room on the set for another,
the director's assistant.
There's not another director,
And as somebody who lives at PA,
somebody who worked in development,
somebody who's,
you know,
uh,
most I don't think I've ever met a director who's assistant was,
was a director and training.
Uh,
and even then you're not getting that experience.
But as an actor,
I got to
have front row seats for every director that I worked with.
So the time I ever directed,
I already,
you know,
there were a half a dozen directors that I thought were great and half a dozen
and I thought weren't great and I emulated the ones that were great.
And being an actor,
you're kind of modeling yourself imitating what the people you respect do.
And that's kind of what musicians do too,
right?
If you,
you know,
you,
everybody practices Hendricks licks first and then they come up with their own
style,
but there is,
uh,
there is,
this,
uh,
mimicking phase of learning and,
and it's tough to get those 10,000 hours under your belt just by going to film
school.
Now maybe it's different because now people can literally take a camera,
go out,
film something,
edit it,
put it up,
get feedback.
See if people like it or they don't,
and they could hit the drawing board again.
It does not cost hundreds of thousands of dollars.
Uh,
they can,
they can do that thanks to technology.
But Tom,
I was coming up,
that wasn't,
that wasn't even an option.
Swingers was done as cheaply as you possibly could for that quality of a film.
And that was,
uh,
almost $200,000 and clerks had been done even cheaper than the budget was
$200,000.
175,
something like that.
Uh,
but the clerks had been done for I think 10,000 or something ridiculous like
that.
And that's,
you know,
that's a feat.
Oh yeah.
Because I haven't done it at a time when it wasn't quite that straightforward.
It was very inspiring to us.
So it was before we had done it and we were like,
why can't we just do it?
Because instead of trying to sell swingers,
we ended up making ourselves.
Uh,
so by the time I had done chef,
it was like I had been wanting to do something.
Everything I was developing,
I was trying to work on as a chef into,
because I want it to be something I wanted to learn about.
So if I was working on a TV pilot or working on,
uh,
developing something for is producing something for somebody else who was like,
oh,
what about an in a restaurant?
What about Hsa?
Because it seemed,
it was a very,
uh,
from watching top chef and following chefs,
reading chefs biographies,
reading kitchen confidential,
which was the first one that I read by Bordain.
Great Book,
Great Book.
And it seemed like there's something here.
Uh,
but it didn't seem like something that warranted its own.
I couldn't see the way to make it into its own thing.
So that was kind of bubbling around my head.
And then something about doing something about being a dad,
being,
um,
we were talking about mindfulness,
about mindfulness in parenting,
about how a few simple,
overseeing a few important things in your life over the course of many years can
ruin your life if you don't invest enough into the,
the things that are important but not pressing.
So if you put everything into your career and not into the things that won't,
there's things that aren't the squeaky wheel but are important,
but not in the short term.
Over time you'll find yourself in a situation that you don't even understand how
you got into,
you know,
when you see it a lot in the chef world is still out in the movie world.
A lot of fail if families that where it doesn't work out.
And a lot of it's because the,
the career demands so much time,
so much effort and creating that balance,
which,
you know,
fortunately I've done,
uh,
the,
the older I get,
the better I get at it.
And,
and,
and now,
uh,
the things are,
you know,
I think well balanced for me,
but I want to make something about somebody where they weren't well balanced.
What if I had made different decisions in my life early on and,
and then looking at it through the idea of the culinary world and,
and having really,
the stories are about growth spurts.
It's about right.
Coming of age.
I'm a big,
I mentioned Joseph Campbell's monomyth yeah,
sorry.
Oh No,
I was saying just the monomyth.
I finally made a,
just a motto,
Manon,
we'll seat detox about,
I,
I become fascinated by Joseph Campbell and the last few years,
uh,
also the,
the how these archetypes,
right.
Uh,
translate across all cultures and indigenous tribal here.
1,000 physiology.
Exactly.
Yeah.
You ever seen speaking of Skywalker that I think the first time that I saw the
Skywalker ranch was on the power of meth with Jesu.
Campbell's interviewed by Bill Moyers.
Oh,
I haven't seen that.
I haven't,
that's one of the first,
uh,
when,
when video first came out,
that was one of the first things that was,
uh,
available in that realm and it's still holds up.
It's great.
I'm sure it's easy to get your hands on the power meth and he's being,
he's in sending in the library at the Skywalker ranch being interviewed of
everything back free now from Adam and even earlier,
all the way through star wars.
And it's like a four part or six part series from PBS,
I think.
And it was great.
That was my introduction to,
to Joseph Campbell.
And then there's books about relating that archetype rise of the hero
storytelling,
two screenplays and how there's less variation than you,
you might think.
And the more you stick to it,
the better.
It just is.
It's,
it's,
those are great to fly with.
And with jungle book,
I really am,
you know,
going back and doubling down on that,
on,
just going back to the,
to the old myths.
And it works so well for,
for Lucas.
Oh yeah.
I mean it's,
uh,
I've been,
I'm fascinated by spy screenwriting and I haven't spent a lot of time looking at
the format,
but I took the story seminar by be key and have read a handful of books.
That's pretty intense.
And that is,
that is intense.
And that book is I've ever gotten all the way through.
I found it very dense.
I've had a difficult,
uh,
there,
there are a handful of others,
like saved the cat that I found very helpful for me personally,
just to think about the storytelling mechanisms.
There's one called,
uh,
if,
if I may,
oh,
of course.
The writer's journey,
the writer's journey,
writer's journey.
Um,
and I,
I'm sorry,
I'm a launch.
I could look it up while we're,
while we're talking.
Oh,
I'll put it in the show notes as well.
Okay.
Hope you'll put it in.
Because what it does is it
takes Joseph Campbell and refines it down from the perspective of somebody think
it was a story executive at Disney and,
um,
and,
and breaks what breaks apart,
what the,
what those archetypes are and how they apply to movies that you would have seen
breaking down movies using that.
And,
and also talking about three act structure as it is a,
as it
pertains to the,
the mythic structure that Campbell talked about with the,
the calling,
the refusal of the call,
the entering into the extraordinary world,
the entering the inmost cave,
the
killing the dragon,
and taking the elixir,
going back and healing the land.
And,
um,
even back when I,
uh,
I even looked at,
I was,
I had
already read the book by the time I had done swingers and looked at swingers.
Oh,
the registry.
So it's been around,
it's been around for awhile.
And I remember reading that book
and seeing if it,
if I was structurally correct with swingers and,
and I was satisfied that I was.
But the trick I think is not to use it as a map too,
right?
Because you have to write,
I think you just have to brain dump when you write.
I don't think you could try to control your writing too much.
Um,
for me,
some people are very different people who come out of,
you know,
where they're creating series arcs for a television show it becomes,
you have to delve a group mind and you use the dry erase board and you plot
things out.
It may change but it's very well thought through.
And I find that people that have come from that background tend to like to
outline a lot.
And then there are other people who just come from pros and creative writing or
uh,
you know,
storage,
short story writers that where they just want to,
you know,
the routine has more to do with
what time of day they write,
how much coffee they have before they do,
you know,
getting into that,
uh,
getting into the creative routine,
that's where their structure is.
There's always some form of structure.
Sometimes instructors in the writing seminars,
instructors in the writing,
the act of writing.
Um,
but I found,
I find that for me,
I like to do,
I like to outline a little bit.
I like to,
I first they do so,
so here's what you're getting back to chef.
So with chef I those two thoughts of wanting to write something about the chef
world and wanting to do something about mindfulness in parenting,
both crashed into each other.
And I got the idea of the epiphany hit me that,
um,
that I,
this is,
this could all come together in a project.
Let me write this thing.
And I,
and I took out,
I like composition.
I know you like the minutia.
I do.
I love the minutiae.
So composition mean composition,
notebooks,
you know the black and white flecks cover cardboard.
Sure.
Someone's spine.
It looks kinda like a zebra.
The black and white on the cover.
Exactly.
I like those because I find,
um,
I think it's from my drawing days,
when I used to get like a really nice leather bound drawing paper sketch book
that'd be so reluctant to,
to defile it.
Yeah.
Like is this drawing good enough for my cause it was always felt like a show
piece,
whereas the,
the notebooks seemed like,
um,
because everybody grew up with them like as their first notebook that there's a
freedom and marking it up,
but you can't rip pages out.
Right.
So you can't self edit because if you do,
the book falls apart.
So it's not like a spiral.
He can't use a spot for me.
He can't use a spiral.
So I have,
for everything I've done and there's a lot of incomplete projects,
I'll,
I'll get a composition notebook,
I'll date it,
title it,
and then just start filling it with,
uh,
some string of consciousness,
sometimes,
um,
a list of movies that I want to look at that relate to this a book,
uh,
image something.
And it becomes my,
you know,
that's where we're just brain dump.
And so for,
for a chef that was actually meditating,
I was meditating and the two things hit each other.
And usually if I'm meditating,
uh,
which I try to do at least once a day,
um,
although I don't always,
but I find that in part of the distraction of meditating,
uh,
creative thoughts might pop into my head,
but that seems to be a distraction.
So I have to push past those.
It's,
it's Kinda like on the highway entrance.
First you have everything you're worried about,
hit you,
then you start to have
creative thoughts that are interesting and inspiring.
But those will,
those will trick you into not meditating too.
So like these are all obstacles that you have to kind of pass by.
Um,
and then,
and then you get into the,
the good part.
If there's such a thing,
I know you're not supposed to judge it or think about it any,
but,
but you get into that brain wave or whatever that thing is.
It seems to be the experience that,
that when you meditate that you,
that you seek,
um,
that kind of,
okay.
Thoughtless [inaudible] the full devoid of sort of loading in the void.
I don't know if I get as far as the void,
but for me that's how I feel.
But that's good.
I don't know if I'm that good.
How do you meditate?
What type of meditation?
Just,
you know,
um,
do you focus on your breath?
Do you focus on something else that,
that TM or breath or a,
I tried different things,
but now you know,
honestly it's like I don't even,
it's,
it's more of like an exercise now.
Like I know how to get to,
uh,
I think it's,
it might be a brainwave pattern,
I don't know,
but it's a state of mind that I could hit without really tricks.
I kinda just need to take me about five or six minutes and I could get there.
Do you sit in a chair with your feet on the floor or you like scolded different?
Tried to lay down cause you fall asleep.
Right.
Yeah.
Um,
but I tried to do that.
I used to do it.
Um,
I haven't found a place ever.
It's nice when you can do at the same time every day.
I just switched from production to post production on this,
so I don't,
I don't,
I haven't gotten into my routine.
I haven't been doing it as much as I should,
but otherwise I'd like to.
But,
but,
uh,
a in the middle of it,
I got the,
the idea for chef hit me and I let myself stop,
which I don't usually do.
And I took out a pad and I just scribbled out at like eight pages of,
of,
of ideas and thoughts and um,
I left it alone and then write it.
And it had,
you know,
if I look back on it and read those pages,
it really had 80% of the heavy lifting done as far as what it was about,
who was in it,
who the characters were.
Um,
what other movies to look at,
what the tone is,
what music I would have in it,
what type of food he was doing,
the idea of the food truck and then the Cuban sandwiches and Cuban music and,
and uh,
he's from Miami and um,
and so it all sort of grew out from that.
And then I went ahead and I have enough half written screenplays that I just
forced myself to keep writing every day.
Uh,
and so this only took me a few weeks to,
to get the first draft,
but the big thing was I was so scared of,
of of,
it's like the Cube Lecan dream,
the poem Qube Lecan right.
It wasn't that the story that,
that,
that it was a dream and only part of it was written down cause he forgot it all.
Uh,
the poet,
I think I have that.
I think I have that right.
Going back to school,
I don't remember the details.
Right.
But the idea that sometimes you feel like when you're writing a story or a
screenplay,
if you let enough time pass in the first draft,
you get off of that,
that kind of,
um,
get out of the gate of the zone on your on.
Yeah.
Because I don't think it's something you control.
I think it's something you access and,
and um,
I don't think,
I'm not,
not to say it's from some other mystical place,
but whatever,
that part of your brain that it comes from is,
uh,
is not a part of your brain that you necessarily can force to do what you want.
It's not,
they're not fully domesticated.
Right?
Yeah.
You gotta Kinda to kind of trick it into doing its thing.
And when you did the,
the brain dump down into the composition notebook,
do you take then I'd imagine these are not necessarily in chronological order.
It's just a full on brain dump.
Some of its chronological,
then you go back and hit another part of it and then run it through again.
And so it does,
it goes,
go on a little tears.
It's like a pitch session,
except you're alone.
And when you said tone,
what would be an example of,
of tone for a movie?
How would you sort of write that down or describe that?
Eat,
drink,
man.
Woman opening.
Like that stuff.
Right.
Fantastic.
One big night.
Um,
you know,
a lot of it's movies,
a lot of it is one of it's a social club soundtrack.
Um,
food truck,
food,
Cuban sandwiches,
uh,
the sun,
the,
there's a divorce,
they've been separated,
but they get along,
get along.
And he's with,
he's stuck.
He's with,
uh,
he's a,
there's a critic coming.
Yeah.
This is it.
That's there's Braca two.
It's the only,
so many,
there's only so many cooking a restaurant.
Movies you can make.
And the guy is preparing the,
he's goes to the farmer's market and brings his kid with him.
Like,
so there's,
there's moments,
there's vignettes,
there's,
um,
images.
Um,
and some of them are sequences and some of them are movies.
And sometimes it's movies that are in your memory.
And then when you see the movie,
it's not that,
but it's the version in your head from what you remember of a movie and then
you,
and then kitchen confidential.
I remember referencing that a lot and,
and who the characters are.
And I wanted a very,
a lot of,
uh,
Latino cast members because that's what was really kitchen confidential.
I remember like that's really what kitchens were and what I saw and what it was
and never what was depicted.
And how does that,
the,
how does the vibrance of that culture with the music playing in the kitchen and
then they're cooking food that's not that.
And then in,
in being a re
inspired,
he's inspired by that.
Who,
the people that are surrounding him,
the music he's listening to and where he came from in Miami.
And maybe that's the type of food he used to cook it.
Now he's cooking very trendy,
you know,
a user friendly food that wasn't inspiring to him.
And,
and then being frustrated by not being inspired by his,
his art is no longer inspiring him and he's hit an impasse and they also at the
impasses affecting both his professional life,
but in a way he's not aware of his personal life too.
He's,
he's stuck spiritually stuck.
Okay.
And on the,
on the show business side of things,
this is something I know very little about,
but in terms of the,
the,
the actual making,
selling,
distributing of the film,
uh,
and feel free to correct me if I get this wrong,
when I've heard you refer to,
I think making chef has,
going back to basics.
Yes.
Uh,
and sort of constraining the size or the,
or budget so that you could do certain things like have the language you want it
to have in the movie,
for instance,
be authentic.
Uh,
how,
how did you make this movie?
And I know that's a very novice question,
but,
uh,
I've,
I've talked to people sort of indirectly,
you've gone through the big studio process and have had a very rough time of it.
What made chef different?
How did you,
uh,
or swingers you could comment on that?
Again,
I think,
I think it's all a matter of,
um,
it's,
it's all a matter of adjusting to what the,
of,
what the environment is at any given moment and adjusting in art of war kind of
way.
I don't think about it in those terms but,
but acknowledge what the terrain is.
And I think a lot of what seems like a,
in my career in general as though I've had this vision for how my career was
going to change and things I would try to do and,
and to get things accomplished was,
was more a reaction to what the circumstances were.
So for example,
I thought swingers,
we opened a lot of doors for me acting wise it didn't,
uh,
I got to do a little bit of stuff here and there.
It was fun,
but I was very sought after as a writer after that.
And so the writer door opened up,
the actor door was,
you know,
kind of more of a,
more of a small,
you know,
a little cracked open door.
That occasion I could poke my nose through.
But it wasn't receiving me,
but the,
but the writer door was wide open.
So I started to do that and I learned a lot about storytelling and interacting
with executives and what the system was by being involved with projects and none
of which that ever got actually produced with the versions that I wrote.
But I was part of a chain of writers on,
on,
on certain projects.
Um,
so I would,
I was pretty good at,
at adjusting to what path was available to me and finding something interesting
about what was available,
but without ever feeling that I was compromising.
But just trying to check out something that could be cool and not getting in my
own way of saying,
why shouldn't I be a writer on this?
Why not pitch this
take on a movie even though I've never done a rewrite?
Why,
why not go in there and talk to them about this?
And,
and so I've had,
I think I've had enough confidence to not be scared to try something new,
which I think is something that gets in a lot of people's ways.
I think people get in their own way a lot and there are certain things that I'm,
you know,
that I have been scared of but,
but for some reason careerwise maybe it's my early upbringing.
I don't know what,
but I,
I never feel intimidated when I'm in a room with people or if I'm on stage in
front of people.
Like I don't,
I don't get that.
My,
my heart doesn't,
doesn't race in those situations.
And those even before the Improv.
Yeah,
I've always been comfortable like getting in front of people and talking and
I've been a bit of a ham when I was little,
like loving the jump up in front of the family and put on shows.
I just think certain people wire now that I have three kids for sure,
you just kind of wired a certain way and certain people are,
you know,
kind of,
they kind of have certain things that they like and certain things that they're
good at and you could adjust them and change them,
but you're kind of kind of working with her,
you know,
you're kind of handed it.
It's like,
it's like poker.
You get a d,
You know,
you get,
you get dealt a hand and you could play those cards well or poorly,
but,
but you're definitely working from,
um,
you know,
you're definitely inheriting your properties in risk at the beginning of the
game.
You know what I mean?
You're,
you're,
you're starting from a certain vantage point and,
and then,
and then it's,
what do you do with that,
with,
with a movie like swingers for instance.
And again,
this is,
these are just things that I've heard quoted,
so feel free to correct me if I'm wrong.
It seems like everyone has seen swingers.
I mean,
it gets,
it gets quoted all the time.
Um,
the box office was around 6 million.
It was if that,
if that it was considered,
you know,
so.
So just to give you a perspective,
we,
you know,
trying to get it made for a year.
Nobody gives us the money.
Doug Liman is able to raise the money and we make it together.
What is his,
uh,
he's,
I guess director got the director of the film,
but when I had met him,
I was trying to set it up as a director.
I was trying to direct it and he had already done a film.
Uh,
he was just part of a circle of friends.
Did not very,
uh,
I wasn't very close with him,
but I knew him through somebody else.
And he was somebody who had directed.
And so I had bought him a cup of coffee.
He talked me through lenses and it was preparing me for when it was time for me
to direct.
And then in that process had said,
look,
I know you,
you,
you know,
hopefully you will get to put this thing together,
but um,
but I can raise the money.
And,
and so we agreed to creatively be partners on this thing and,
and um,
and we made it a much smaller budget and I thought it was possible this was the
200 [inaudible] 200 k that he was able to bring and figure out how to bring that
movie to the screen with that budget,
with the experience that he had had.
So,
uh,
so that it happened,
we tried to get into Sundance and not to interrupt,
but was he that financing from sort of independently wealthy individuals or was
it from companies are,
I think it was more like that.
Yeah,
I think it was more of the connections that he had had from growing up in town
and being involved with,
uh,
you know,
there were,
there were people that he knew that were willing to bet on him as some of it was
based on stuff he had done already.
And some of it was,
um,
you know,
uh,
that he,
you know,
had passionate about this thing,
but he was able to get the,
the secure the financing.
Got It.
So,
uh,
so the,
the first experience was that,
um,
then,
then we made it and that was real seat of the pants and then we didn't get into
Sundance,
which was our goal was to get in.
That was the be all and end all for us.
And I know if it was that it wasn't finished enough or we had just just pulled
it,
you know,
a cut together for them where it was screened on videotape versus a screening,
who knows what it was,
was incredibly disappointing us.
So it felt like all was lost.
Then we put up,
uh,
after Sundance,
that Sundance festival,
when everybody had gotten back,
we had done our own screening in Los Angeles for the cast and crew and invited
some distributors to it as well.
And it played extraordinary extraordinarily well there.
And then we had multiple buyers and you know,
you don't have to be in Hollywood to know what that means,
you know,
more than one person is interested.
It's a whole different dynamic.
And now there was a,
a bit of a bidding war over.
It ended up selling for $5 million and there's a distribution rights,
distribution rights.
And,
um,
and so we were,
we were riding high.
It was,
you know,
in all the,
all,
everybody wants to interview us and everybody wanted to feature us in their
magazines and we were like the next thing.
And,
and so when,
like the year between when it was a acquired and when it came out that we were
riding very high,
Vincent,
I think God cast in,
uh,
the SQL to Jurassic Park,
which is as bad as big as you can get.
And everybody who was,
nobody was now had a seat at the table,
had another shot,
you know,
uh,
and,
and then by the time the movie came out,
it opened,
first weekend is in whatever,
two theaters for theaters who was huge box office.
And then a few weeks later,
nobody cared and it made $5 million and,
and it was considered a failure at the box office wise.
Cause you've got to figure out,
one side of us was like Slingblade that made $100 million in one Oscars on the
other side was um,
goodwill hunting that won Oscars and made like $100 million.
So we were kind of a disappointing,
uh,
underperformer at Miramax at that point.
And so all of it kind of ebbed away.
But again,
it was,
it was enough to get my foot in the door as a writer.
And,
uh,
I had already,
now I had not just been the guy who was in Rudy as a,
as a character actor,
but now I been in this movie that as you said,
everybody has seen.
So,
uh,
thanks to video and later DVD and the earlier on laser disk,
everybody had seen this film and it become part of our culture.
And that's what I kind of learned,
that it's not always the movie that does the best,
that has the most impact.
Where's the most rewarding or does the most of your career for that matter?
Even though in the short term,
successes is celebrated here and failures on forgivable.
Uh,
but over time I think that it,
that shifts a bit.
And I know for example,
like Vince had gotten Jurassic Park on the heels of swingers.
He's far more recognized now from swingers that grossed one,
you know,
not even a 10th,
uh,
maybe a hundredth of what that movie made.
But for some reason this one has had more impact on his career,
even though a far less people went to see it in the movie theater.
So you never know what's gonna.
And I,
and I find in my own career the same thing.
It's not always the things that make the most money.
It's the things that the performances or there's something about certain
projects that stick in people's memories more.
Yeah,
the staying power.
And I was,
I was astonished as I started studying film more and looking at movies that had
a huge impact on me or were these landmark iconic films among the high school
and college males who are the majority of my friends in fight club,
for instance.
And I was astonished that it wasn't some massive,
massive aging bull,
you know,
was,
all these movies that are sort of failures in the,
and the,
in the,
uh,
in the beginning and up or Rudy was my first experience with a movie coming out.
It didn't do well at,
I'll do a new number one at the box office was considered also an under
performer,
but now everybody knows it.
It's a cultural,
um,
you know,
it's,
it's a cultural point of reference.
Uh,
I hear the music everywhere.
I people refer to it constantly.
So like those are the ones where you make the ripple,
the cultural ripple.
And that's honestly the thing that is most exciting,
that that's the most appealing to me is how can you impact,
how can you make that kind of impact and affect people and either touch them,
entertain them,
make them laugh,
make them feel connected.
You know,
that's the,
that's the part that's the most rewarding at this point in my career.
And,
uh,
I am keeping an eye on the time.
I know that,
uh,
you've been very generous with your time and I'll only take a few more minutes.
Uh,
the W it would be remiss of me if I didn't mention that a number of my fans have
said to thank you for chef.
They've rented at five to 10 times just to show friends.
So I think that,
that,
that's all I think that's going to be one of the movies.
And I think that's really what,
that's was kind of a thing.
I know within like the,
the chef
community,
they accepted it,
the ones that I've met.
So that was a big scary part of it for me.
Cause if,
if everybody,
if people had liked to,
who didn't know about that world and,
but then the people who are in the world didn't like it,
it would have been
a mixed,
it went to felt good to me.
Um,
but the fact that people are seeing it now,
like I,
uh,
I'm spending more time with my son after seeing the movie or you know what?
I'm going to try to open up my own business that I've been putting off forever.
And that's when you feel really humbled and good and flattered because you feel
like you're connecting.
It's a selfishly,
just a very good feeling to know that,
that you're,
uh,
you're me being on this planet has changed somebody else's experience,
like in a,
in a good way.
And it feels,
it feels,
um,
you feel connected to people,
which I think is of part of the,
the trip here.
That's part it kind of part of the goal.
Oh,
for sure.
Well,
I think anything with a basis and storytelling at some point,
I mean,
you're making a lot of connections through this.
Uh,
I think there's,
we are hardwired for this,
this Joseph Campbell like experience even in our own lives.
Um,
I'd love to ask just a couple of rapid fire questions.
The first is,
when you hear the word successful,
who's the first person that comes to mind?
Wow.
Oh,
I like listening to this on your show.
I don't like answering it.
Um,
let's see.
I guess
just a straight knee jerk knee jerk gates.
Okay.
And not be,
you know why?
Because,
because I'm not because of the richest guy,
but because of his,
because of how he shifted his,
um,
his priorities because he's now making tremendous impact with the hand he's been
dealt or the,
the,
the pot that he's built up
that he's making a,
that there's one,
there's like,
there's like the bill gates from,
there's the Microsoft Bill Gates and there's the Post Microsoft Bill Gates.
And,
and to me there's something fascinating about that and that he was able to be
effective in what his goals were for the first
chapter and then what his goals are now,
which are very different.
So he was able to shift his entire
shift,
his entire
agenda
and,
and be effective.
He completely effective on this area.
Similar metric driven,
hardcore approach.
And I don't know a lot about the,
honestly,
I bet this is purely layman's perspective of hey,
there's a lot of,
this is how many lives have been saved by this or this is the,
mmm.
This many people have agreed to have charitable donations,
but it's just,
uh,
there's something that,
that he's just the first name that popped into my head.
Any particular director who comes to mind?
Director or writer?
There's a few,
you know,
and they're all different.
Like I worked with [inaudible],
um,
and I think that he's been,
I think there's a certain,
it must be w when I came up and what he represented,
and then I got to meet with him and see him work.
And so he's inspired me as far as what his body of working and who he is as a
person.
Uh,
but I also think of like the Cohen Brothers who've managed to
tickle their own fancy and enjoy everything they're doing and have tremendous
variety and entertain people as well,
but seem to have
maintained a certain balance,
a healthy balance between their work and,
and their private lives.
And they,
I haven't dealt with them that much,
but they see my genuinely like well adjusted normal nice people who happen to
make really exciting,
cool movies.
And then Jim Cameron,
who's sort of the other end of the spectrum,
who's kind of the guy who's reinvented aspects of the industry over and over
again with tremendous,
uh,
enthusiasm and,
and uh,
and,
and also just
a sharp intellect that's into solving problems and changing the way we do the
magic tricks.
And,
and I'm sure I've certainly inherited a lot of what he,
of the ground that he broke with Avatar with jungle book.
A lot of the same technology allows the same people I'm working with.
So there's a,
you know,
a healthy respect.
And then Walt Disney is another one who,
um,
I had researched quite a bit back around the time of iron man too when we were
referencing him and,
uh,
in the stark expo and the stark,
the old stark archives.
Uh,
but he was a bit of a techie at his time and a bit of a storyteller too.
And so he was doing the,
you know,
what he was doing at his time is like,
it seems like what Pixar is doing now.
It's like cutting edge technology,
great stories,
great emotion,
uh,
telling stories with a different set of tools and nobody ever had before.
And there's something,
there's something really,
uh,
to me,
I think,
uh,
he was,
he's one of those key key figures.
Oh,
it's total hacker.
Uh,
they,
they display a bunch of his old cobbled together macgyver like rigs at the
Disney family museum in San Francisco.
Presidio.
Yeah.
Which is amazing.
What is the book that you've gifted the most other people?
Um,
actually the writer's journey was one of them.
I've given your book,
I've given four hour body the people.
Thank you for that.
Given that,
uh,
um,
those are the biggies.
I'm trying to think of it as anything else.
I did grow when I first started off in acting.
I gifted growed Ann's book to my family.
Uh,
his first book,
it would be so nice if you weren't here because it really told the story about
how difficult it is when you're first starting off trying to be an actor and he
had such a great voice.
Uh,
other than that,
I can't,
not none are jumping or jumping to mind.
That's three though.
Right?
That's plenty.
Uh,
last question.
actually the two,
they're pretty quick.
The first is what advice would you give to your 20 year old self?
Wow.
Um,
uh,
he wouldn't listen.
30 year old self.
MMM.
I think
okay.
To not confuse
how you feel about something with how that thing really is.
I think you think you're being more objective than you really are.
And you were colored by emotion more than you think you are in,
in positive ways and negative ways.
But,
but it's um,
perspective is,
is,
um,
is much more subjective than you.
Thank you.
Think you're a lot more uh,
objective and then you are to me specifically at 30 and 20,
I don't even know how it wasn't even a human being.
What I would say,
it's funny because it's,
part of it is just the ignorance of,
of walking into,
you know,
the the,
the forest and not knowing where I was going and whatever it was getting me
through it.
You know,
thank,
thankfully I had enough,
something in the back of my mind told me to just take that road and walk,
not knowing where it was going.
And so that was,
um,
so I'm very grateful.
I like where I am.
I like what the experience of my life is.
I'd like every year I like better.
I like who I am better.
I like what my life is better.
Um,
so,
uh,
it,
I'm very reluctant to interfere with the way things were,
but I think a lot of is how I feel about things and what I do too,
how I,
how I kind of balance things out,
um,
in a way that is,
is,
uh,
that I'm proud of that I like.
Well,
I love your work and thank you so much for the time.
Where can people find out more about you,
find you online?
He,
let's see.
I don't know.
I uh,
I'm on,
uh,
Twitter and Facebook at John Underscore Fabro uh,
on Twitter and then Facebook I think is just Jon Favreau and Instagram.
Jon Favreau.
It's pretty consistent.
I've been working.
So there's not a lot of stuff up there.
Uh,
you know,
I'm on there when we do like,
we do pop ups once in a while in Los Angeles.
Maybe we'll do one up north,
uh,
for the,
from the food from chef.
Oh,
that'd be great.
So we,
we've been doing that of design to have not only Cuban,
but the grilled cheese sandwich.
I'm sure you must hear about that a lot so I could cook them.
I cook them for the crew at a movie.
I cook them for my kids.
I cook them here at the,
uh,
in the editing rooms.
Uh,
but I enjoy cooking and we've cooked together.
I think we have,
I reveal that definitely.
I have a cooked,
cooked [inaudible].
That was an amazing experience for Superbowl.
Oh,
good.
You had never done that before.
I know it was.
That was what we're talking about.
Here we were,
we didn't really know each other that well.
I read your stuff,
you saw my stuff,
and then Lo and behold,
you put some,
some hot oil there and the focus is no longer.
I want an honor.
Thank you for your,
your,
uh,
fingers out scalded keeping all your fingers.
Well,
John,
thank you so much.
Uh,
there's,
there's tons more to explore.
Everybody.
I'll put links in the show notes too,
where you could find John and thanks so much for your [inaudible].
All right,
great.
And thank you too.
I love,
I love the podcast,
but I,
uh,
you've,
um,
I know this is about me,
not about you,
but I,
I,
I got to know you through your writing and uh,
I was very,
you're very,
uh,
intriguing.
I get pulled into your work.
You make it very easy to read your stuff.
It had been recommended,
I think for our body was recommended to me.
And one of those things where you just pick a chapter here,
chapter there,
next thing you know,
you're reading the whole thing and your approach to,
uh,
questioning things and curating research and fact based,
but not being,
you know,
it seems like there's always,
you always are either dealing with,
dealing with the scientific method where something has to have been through a
double blind study or at completely anecdotal.
There's,
there was no middle ground of what's interesting about,
about your stuff as you'll say,
hey look,
here's what I've experienced.
Here's the sample that I've seen this experience with.
It's not something that should be looked at scientifically,
but there are certain indications that this is worth looking into more.
And here's what I do and here's what I've done.
And it makes it much more inviting than either the very walled off world of
traditional academia and academia.
And then also this,
uh,
I dunno,
science that's more based on,
on anecdotal information that doesn't take science into consideration as much.
But to acknowledge that science has an importance to it,
but also looking at how,
uh,
what has not yet gone through that machine might have some truth to it too.
And giving full disclosure of your context and why makes it not,
um,
intellectually offensive.
You know,
it feels like you're,
it could be responsible intellectually,
not flying in the face of science,
but,
but you're also opening it up to new ways of thinking and,
and you know,
I think it relates to the way you,
your context,
the whole world that you're the whole northern California way of ethos of
looking at things and how to,
how,
how to be more effective and efficient in,
uh,
in approaching problems that we still face.
So,
uh,
I love looking at your stuff and like I said,
thank you.
The three,
the four hour chef was really was a great a counterbalance to the other chef,
um,
biographies that I was reading or autobiographies or,
uh,
cooking books and documentaries.
I was watching.
And then here was the,
uh,
a very concise version of a lot of the same information.
Um,
that was a really good,
a really good counterbalance.
Well,
I,
I really appreciate it and I love watching your experiments.
I love watching you do the,
the huge blockbusters than do chef.
I can't wait to see what you do next.
Well,
I know,
I guess I'm waiting to see jungle book,
Jungle Book right here.
It's going to be amazing.
It's going to be something different and cool.
And you know,
just like everything else,
the doing,
doing one with this level of technology,
which I,
you know,
I got a taste of here and there with iron man,
but to really throw the,
throw the whole thing into have the home movie rely on that magic trick working
is,
uh,
it's,
um,
exhilarating,
but if it all works as well as it looks like it will,
it's,
it'll be something nobody had seen before.
So it's,
it's exciting stuff.
I can't wait to see it and we'll John to be continued.
Thank you so much for the time.
Right.
My pleasure.
This was fun.
It was quick and easy.
Quick and easy.
All right,
thanks.
Take care.
But Tim Ferriss show is brought to you by on it.
I have used on IT products for years.
If you look in my kitchen in my garage,
you will find Alpha brain chewable Melatonin for resetting my clock when I'm
traveling.
Kettlebells,
battle ropes,
maces steel clubs.
It sounds like a torture chamber and it kind of is.
It's a torture chamber for self improvement and you can see all of my favorite
gear at [inaudible] dot com forward slash Tim.
That's o,
n n I t.com forward slash Tim and you can also get a discount on any
supplements,
food products.
I like him some.
I like Alpha brain.
Check it all out on it.com forward slash Tim,
the Tim Ferriss show is also brought to you by 99 designs.
99 designs is your one stop shop for anything graphic design related.
You need a logo,
you need a website,
you need a business card or anything else.
You get an original design from designers around the world who submit drafts for
you to review.
You are happy or you get your money back.
And I have used 99 designs for book cover ideas for the four hour body,
which went to Number One New York Times for banner ads,
and you can check out some of my actual competitions@ninetyninedesigns.com
forward slash.
Tim,
you can also get a free $99 upgrade if you want to give it a shot.
That's 99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim and until next time,
thanks for listening.